faites attention ne restez pas là
le vent glacé souffle en rafales à plus
de 120 km heure la municipalité vient de
déclarer l'état d'urgence
les habitants ont interdiction de sortir
de chez eux
derrière leurs fenêtres certains
assistent au spectacle d'une nature
déchaînée
mon dieu le toit temps de le toit tombe
[Musique]
nous devons soir bienvenue sur les ondes
de télé canal de russie le programme
d'information sur norilsk norilsk qui
est actuellement touchée par une forte
vague de tempête il y à un moment trop
victimes des piétons l'un d'eux est
décédé
le vent est puissant il faut rester chez
vous ne sortez pas même pour acheter du
pain
la tempête a ravagé une partie de la
ville regarde que le vent a fait ça peut
tomber ça nous il ya eu des bourrasques
de vent et elles ont littéralement
arraché le toit de l'immeuble
c'est vraiment dangereux il soc 2 reste
qu'un poisson insultes watts/heure la
ferraille du toit veulent comme ça au
dessus des gens des voitures c'est
effrayant
sergei et sa famille ne sont pas les
seuls à ignorer les consignes de
sécurité droit qui attendent noire de
monde
prenons de briques de lait cette marque
là c'est bien sa cage
oui comme ça change nous sommes obligés
de faire vite parce que l'aéroport est
fermé et bientôt il n'y aura plus
d'approvisionnement ici c'est pour ça
que nous devons acheter beaucoup chéri
prend lui la grosse bouteille
le blizzard signifie la fermeture de
l'aéroport et donc la rupture du
ravitaillement de la ville
car à norilsk aucune culture ni
d'élevage
tout est importé sauf le poisson et là
vous allez pouvoir tenir combien de
jours non mais si on se fie à notre
expérience le blizzard ne devrait pas
durer plus de cinq jours
je pense que nous aurons assez de
provisions jusqu'à la fin de la tempête
[Musique]
à l'extérieur la tempête semble sur le
point de se lever à nouveau
[Musique]
après cinq jours de bourrasques
incessantes le passage de la tempête est
visible à chaque coin de rue
[Musique]
la catastrophe climatique a fait deux
morts